Make sure you guys hit the subscribe button.
If you guys are enjoying the content that we're throwing up and make sure you
guys hit the like button, if you enjoyed the video and yeah, let's begin.
All right. What's going on guys.
Is Rob and we are picking back up again with Batman. Again,
we're kind of continuing the aftermath of joker war,
but this time we are picking up with Batman's new villain,
that ghost maker and this guy's cool. And I dig was happening here.
Here's the funny thing is I didn't expect like ghosts maker to encounter Batman
for like another three issues are so wide off the bat. Like you have you,
you like literally in this first issue,
Batman takes this guy on and it's kinda crazy, right? It's kind of wonky here.
So, um, because of the fact that this is kind of the aftermath of joker war,
we're still gonna see some themes from that story being thrown in.
But the first thing we do here is we get this bit of an exposition right in
downtown Gotham city, really in an old town, uh,
you've got basically ghost ghost maker talking to this cough,
and this cop's been captured.
This guy's been strung up and ghost makers kind of giving us this perspective of
Gotham city, right. In the sense that he hates Gotham city.
But here's the funny thing about this is it's not this typical,
like I hate Gotham city.
It's one of these things where he's kind of like this city is not going to
improve more so than that. He goes,
as far as to say that he realized pretty early on that he was not going to
improve here.
So the first bit of indication we get in terms of the story of ghost maker is
that he seems to originate from Gotham city.
And then ultimately he ended up leaving the place that from his perspective,
the city smells of like urine and blood and violence and death.
It's just a really crappy place to be.
But the funny thing about this is that in, in his mind, he kind of says like,
this city should be burned to the ground,
but instead of taking this almost kind of like dark Knight rises approach where
it's like, I'm going to poison people's souls and that kind of stuff. Instead,
his idea is if I had all the billions of the world like Bruce Wayne does,
I would relocate all of you,
burn the city to the ground and then let you rebuild it into something better.
That's actually not a bad approach. It's violent,
but it's basically taking the city as it's so twisted and screwed up,
tearing it all down and then letting the people build it up into something
better. So it's not wholly like a villainous approach.
There's actually some good there.
And that's one of the things that struck me right off the bat in terms of the
nature of this guy. He's not a wholesale villain, right?
He's not a straight up bad guy.
And so what this guy basically says is this cop is kind of strung up and you
know, he's like, he's like, you know, what is it that you want, right. Like,
why are you saying all this? And the response of ghost maker is my ghost net,
right?
So basically his technology has made its way into the computer systems of Gotham
and he knows every single crime that's going on. And he's like,
I'm going to solve all of them for you.
But what you're going to do to me in return is you're going to give me a
location of clown Hunter.
You're going to tell me how to find this clown Hunter kit.
And it's kind of a crazy thing because this cop's like, we're not dirty, right?
I'm like, I'm not a dirty cop. I'm not just going to give you information,
right? You, you back guys don't work that way. And so he's like, I'm not Batman,
right? Like I'm the ghost maker. I'm better than Batman.
And I'm here to prove that I am right now. From there.
It switches over to what is effectively a new concept in DC comics? Well,
I guess new is a bit of a misnomer. We pick up with a group called the grinners.
The reason why I say this is kind of new,
but kind of not back in the 1940s backbone back when it was timely comics before
it became Atlas comics. And then eventually Marvel comics.
You had a line of comics that were called misery colleagues.
You had a line of comics called mystery comics,
which are exactly what they sounded like, right?
This was before Marvel became the superhero publishing house that,
that we know it to be now right before Spider-Man and the fantastic fork,
they publish mystery stories, right? Sometimes there were ghost stories.
Sometimes there were science fiction.
But the idea here is that back then what you had is in mystery comics,
number seven, you had to create her name.
Dr. Weems and Dr. Rims was a guy who was trying to find a kind of cure for
pneumonia.
And it was really more of model's attempt to kind of build on the Superman
mythos in so far as Superman was a champion of the people he fought against like
government censorship and against like crony politicians and bad,
bad business guys and stuff like that. Right? So the result of this is that in,
in mystery comics, number seven,
Dr. Weems was created by Al Gabriel as a guy who wanted to find a cure for
pneumonia, believed he'd found it experimented on himself.
And then basically ended up becoming a, what was called the grinner.
And this was a guy who had like this really sadistic grin on his face.
It's a pretty cool concept. Right?
But the idea here is that the grinners have actually been around in Gotham city
for a long, long time, right? During the days of like Harley Quinn.
The idea here though, is that the grinners are not your typical joker henchman.
Your typical joker henchmen are guys who were like,
criminals are down on their luck or they're in some weird situation.
And it's just easy money, right? I mean, it's a risk working for the joker.
These are basically guys who were like the most hardcore that whenever the joker
implements these great, big, huge grandiose schemes,
there's some of the first people to act,
but it's more of a desire to prove themselves to the joker than it is actually,
you know, being joker henchman per se. Now, for the most part,
the joker doesn't really seem to mind their actions because what they do falls
part and parcel with this plan. But these are the most diehard of the diehard,
right? These are the most extreme guys.
And whenever the joker isn't really doing anything whenever he doesn't really
have a major plan, they're basically lying low. And that's kind of,
what's been going on here is these guys are effectively lying low.
Now this information is given to Batman by virtue of Oracle, Barbara Gordon.
And one of the things tenon does is he says like right off the bat,
she's not going to stay in this role full time.
She's going to be bouncing back and forth between Oracle and Batgirl. Now,
for those of you guys who are not familiar with the Batman mythos,
if you are familiar with this bear with me for the next minute or two,
those are guys who are not familiar with this in the aftermath of the killing
joke with Barbara Gordon being shot and paralyzed and no longer being allowed to
operate. As, as Batgirl,
this all kind of tied into the events of like crisis on infinite earths rights.
They're kind of distilling the Batman mythos down to a more singular story that
focused on Batman himself. And so for her park,
Barbara Gordon was really sort of consolidated down and suddenly just became an
information broker.
Now this went from the eighties into the nineties and then eventually she
returned back to being back girl again,
but there are a lot of people who look at the character of Oracle and see her as
probably the best version of Barbara Gordon,
because she played a far more prominent role in DC comics than she did his bat
girl. Uh,
basically the information that's given to Batman is this is one of the safe
houses of the, uh, of the, the grinners and none for the most part,
nothing really seems to be going on here, right there,
there are some that are playing pool.
There's some that are shown at the bar that are playing cards,
just kind of staying low key until things pop off.
But the other thing about this is that this is about the clown Hunter kid.
You guys remember him from, uh, joker war. He was this kid that had enough,
the joker doing all the stuff that he was doing and looking at Batman and see
him as a guy who was only really ever a half measure, right? Like, well,
you know, we got to keep them alive.
And though we know they're going to kill people.
We can't kill the villains because we don't kill.
And so the results of that is a clown. Hunter stepped up and said, okay,
if Batman's not going to kill villains, then I will.
And so he basically went on this campaign and started killing all the clowns
with the joker everywhere he found them.
And so what Batman is looking to do here is cut this kid off and basically say,
okay, like,
I'm going to round these guys up and take them to jail before the kid can kill
them. Right. The problem is, as soon as he gets in there,
they're already dead and they weren't killed by count Hunter.
All these guys are already dead, right?
And the reason why Barbara Gordon saw them playing pool or playing cards is
because the video footage that she saw was on a constant loop.
This all just one great, big, huge trap. This specifically is more of a message.
And Batman sees a kind of face graffiti on the wall and then immediately tells
Barbara Gordon deactivate your computer systems, right? Shut it all down,
maintain radio silence. I'll let you know what's going on when this is all over.
Right. So Batman just immediately cuts her off, you know,
and that's when he tells her like this personal thing. And so from here,
we jumped back to, what's basically explained as many years ago,
what we ended up doing is picking up in Dublin and we have this guy named Tommy
it's either Tommy to vain or Tommy Giovanni. Um, I would say Tommy Giovanni,
if he was Italian, but the guy looks like he's Irish. Right? So Tommy to vain,
it really, you know, w whatever the case is, uh, I mean, the guys, you know,
Irish, cause you know, he's in Ireland. Uh, but, um, yeah, you know,
for those of you guys across the pond who are more familiar,
like whether you're in Britain or whether you're actually in Ireland proper,
you guys can probably answer this question better than I could.
Is it actually Tommy Giovanni or Tommy to vain,
but you ended up having Bruce Wayne showing up here and literally throwing this
guy out the window.
Now it's not because of the fact that Bruce Wayne's got a bone to pick is
because of Bruce. Wayne wants Tommy to train him, right? He's like,
I'm trying to get your attention. You wouldn't listen to me in the bar.
So now I have your full attention. You're going to teach me everything.
You know, you're the best knife wielder in the world.
You're the best at using knives and knowing how to throw them at people,
how to utilize them. So like, you're going to,
you're going to teach me and I'm going to show you that I'm a worthy pupil,
right? I'm going to beat the crap out of you.
And you're going to show me that you're there.
Then I'm gonna show you I'm worth a. And you're gonna teach me, right.
The problem with this is that you end up having a guy who seemingly it comes out
of nowhere. Now, Bruce Wayne recognizes this kit. And of course,
given the circumstance, this is basically ghost or when he was younger. Right.
I mean, given the nature of the comic, but like Batman, you know,
Bruce Wayne is kind of like, okay, like I recognize this kid,
which indicates that Bruce Wayne knew who he was.
They knew each other in Gotham city. And he basically says like,
I'm the new student, right? Like I'm the new student? Like,
like you Bruce Wayne, like you're just a rich kid. Right?
He was still crying over the fact that his mommy and daddy died. Like,
that's all you really are. See,
that's why I say in Batman begins the best description of Bruce Wayne. Right?
The best,
the best definition of Bruce Wayne came when he went to go meet a carbine
Falcone, I think it was who it was, who was played by Tom Wilkinson. And like,
he goes into the bar and he goes in there with a hand gun,
like he's going to shoot him. And they literally sit them down.
They take his gun away and Tom, Wilkinson's talking to him, you know?
And he's like, he's like, he's like, you're, you're Bruce Wayne. Right?
You're the, the,
the Prince of Gotham you'd have to go a thousand miles to find someone who
doesn't know your name. Right? Like you've never tasted desperate.
You've never known what it meant to struggle. Right?
You think because your mommy and daddy got shot that you really understand what
the darker nature of the world is. Like, like, you don't understand this world.
You're just like a rich kid who lost his mom and dad. You know,
the first thing about this criminal underworld.
But it's one of these things where like ghost maker really seems to kind of
reiterate this message. You're going on a crusade.
Do you want to come become some great, big,
huge superhero who can take on criminals?
Because you feel like you really understand the criminal element because a
criminal shot your mom and dad. No, no, no.
I'm a person who really understands the, the base level of the world. Now,
again, we don't really know much about ghost maker. We don't know if you,
somebody like Thomas Elliot, right.
Or if he's somebody who literally is just from like the worst part of Gotham and
somehow knew Bruce Wayne in their past,
but it's like lived in and just the struggle and strife that comes with being in
Gotham city, right? Just the lowest of the low, right.
Living down in the lower class, the lower class of society in the worst way.
But what you end up getting is basically these two guys who were essentially
fighting each other, right? Like, there's this guy, you know, ghost maker says,
look, if you want him to train you,
you're going to have to go through me because I'm already a student.
So let's get this on.
And when they get into an initial scuffle right off the bat,
Bruce Wayne is completely outclassed.
And that's kind of the crazy thing here is this like, he's literally like,
you're still too slow, right? You're still not fast enough to keep up with me.
That's what really seems to lend credence to the idea that ghost maker really is
just a better fighter than Bruce Wayne across the board. That's kind of the,
the,
the crazy thing here is what we ended up doing is switching back to the modern
day. But switching back to the present day,
you've got Harley Quinn meeting with the landlord, right? And she's like,
I'm going to rent this apartment. And he's like, no,
you're not a reasonable human being. Like, you're your Harley Quinn.
You bring nothing but problems. She's like, look, I'll pay you double rent,
right? Like I'll pay you twice. The rent that you normally make.
And then we'll be cool right now, of course, this guy being a landlord,
money talks, it's just the way, the way of the world.
And so the result of this is that he ends up giving her the room, right?
Letting her, letting her rent the room. And while all that's going on,
you have her being washed by clown Hunter who is essentially preparing to blow
the whole place up. Now, here's the funny thing about it.
The guy's watching videos about how to make his own homemade rocket launcher,
right? He's like, thanks Mr. Internet.
I sure am ready to create my own rocket launcher and fire it into a person's
home. That's, that's a little, that's a little extreme,
but he's literally learning from the internet.
The problem with this is that he's basically met by the arrival of ghost maker
and ghost maker is like, we're going to kill this kid right off the bat.
And that's kind of the crazy thing is that like, when this kid's talking to him,
he's like, you know, I'm not really sure that I like you, you know?
And he's like, well, you know, um, I'm sure that's a good thing, right?
Like you really shouldn't like me because in a minute I'm going to kill you.
But like, you know, here in Gotham city,
Batman is in the business of like taking criminals and putting them in jail and
hoping they stay there. And then like, you know, when they get out,
running them back up again, the Batman looks around and says,
it's not my job to keep them and keep them in jail.
That's the criminal justice system's job. And yes,
the criminal justice system is flawed, but like, it's their job to fix it.
Right. I'm just basically the dog catcher. It's not my place to change things.
It's just my place to enforce things. Right. But like at the end of the day,
it's kind of like this guy's lazy, but he's just a lazy superhero is all it is.
Right. I mean, if you have the ability to change things,
then it's your job to change things.
And the criminal justice system doesn't work well then as you're as a self
appointed superhero in Gotham, because remember,
it's not as though Gotham appointed Batman, Batman chose that. He's like,
I am going to protect Gotham city.
And then going to define how it is that I do it on my own base on this super
screwed up and flawed justice system is one of these things where you kind of
called into the whole nature of proofs right now, of course,
that leads to Batman jumping in,
but in immediately tacking ghost maker and just being like, okay,
like we had an agreement, this is my city.
And the response of ghost maker is then do your job.
And that's the crazy thing here because he's like this whole city is rotting
from the inside out it's rotting from the poor and the destitute who stay poor
and who stay living in destitution.
It's rotting from the wealthy who capitalize on them and keep them there.
It's rotting from like the criminals,
they keep escaping from jail and that you keep rounding up and putting it back
instead of,
instead of looking at them and saying they're in cordial human beings,
that the joker will always kill people.
And because of the nature of the joker and the nature of these criminals,
the justice system just can't hold them. Right.
The jails just can't hold these guys. And so,
because jails can't hold them and because they keep getting out and because they
keep killing people that in your desire to believe the justice system can hold
them. You're sacrificing innocent lives. You're getting people killed.
If you were any measure of a man who could do what needed to be done,
you would have killed them a long time ago. You know? And, and that's the,
that's the crazy thing is this guy, ghost maker is not really a villain.
And I liked that philosophy, but I like, I'd like to,
I'd like a character that will look at Batman and say, you're,
you're sacrificing innocent people's lives because you believe that it's wrong
to kill. But if you believe it's wanting to kill, then what's worse here.
Who's worse in this situation,
the person who kills a hundred people or the person who could have stopped them.
And didn't which one of these two people is worse in this circumstance.
And that's,
what's so wild about that is a creature like these super philosophical
discussions, right? There's super philosophical debates over,
over who really is at fault here.
If Batman could kill the joker and he knows Joker's going to kill a whole bunch
of people, isn't Batman at fault here for not killing him.
Isn't that a legitimate case to make there. I think it is.
And so because of that,
these two guys start going at each other and initially Batman kind of takes this
idea of, okay, fine. Didn't like, let's fight this out. And initially it's like,
you know, we're doing this to save clown Hunter,
but the response of ghost maker is no, no, no, no. You and I,
we're not going to play this game. Like we're not going to fight each other.
You know, for the sake of like clown Hunter,
we're going to fight each other for Gotham city. If I defeat you,
I'm going to kill you. And when I do, I'm going to take over Gotham city.
That's the craziest thing about this is like this guy's kind of legit.
And I agree with his philosophies. Like I liked the ghosts maker,
but with that being said, guys, we're gonna bring this video to an end.
If you are new here to come and explain to make sure you guys at the sub button
to become part of the Rob court. Do you guys enjoy this video?
Make sure you drop a light. Now we'll catch you all later.
[Inaudible]
[inaudible].